hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
yesterday I posted a video about uh thin
prints in the bar right areas in the
order flow where there's not necessarily
a lot of uh volume in the two-way
auction right and oftentimes it's the
result of an imbalance in the market and
you know as Traders we tend to mainly
look for imbalances as opposed to areas
where there's a lack of volume trading
and I want to sort of follow up that
video with today's activity here in the
S PS it's uh was it's Monday the 14th
and you know we opened up and then we
opened up a little bit lower in when the
cash session opened traded back up to
around the Futures uh opening price you
know around hanging around uh Friday's
close then we just took off from you
know basically the uh 87 88 89 area all
the way up to uh new Highs at 01 and
eventually we went up uh higher from
there and and
you know anytime you know when I'm
looking at the order flow
um you know anytime I see sort of any
signs of momentum and obviously
imbalances is a sign of momentum but
there's going to be times where you know
you don't have
stacked buying imbalances or stack
selling imbalances to give you a signal
and there's going to be times where like
here today you know this is the opening
price 45.85 it was down a couple of
points from Friday's close so you know
more or less unchanged but we're just
you know when we start hanging around
you know the the opening price it gives
you a sign of you know a market that's
lacking Direction then it bound its
direction and we went up to uh new Highs
at the time and again you know if you're
looking at
stacked imbalances right you have a
stack buying a balance right here you
have a stack selling a balance right
here but the market is just going
sideways right if you were just to
blindly buy this stacked buying and
balance you know the next bar just went
inside and then eventually went lower
here you got stack selling a balance and
if you just immediately got short
because there's a stack selling
imbalance well this didn't work out
because in the next bar didn't even go
any lower it actually went higher than
the Stacked imbalance right so people
say oh you know you're talking so much
uh great stuff about
stacked imbalances but you know here's
two cases where they fail and you know
when a market is
going sideways lacking direction right
no matter what you're trading whether
it's order flow price action technical
indicators if you're in the middle if
you're you're range trading nothing's
going to give you a great signal really
what you want to be looking for is a
signal that we are indeed breaking out
all right so again yesterday I was
talking about
um thin prints okay and I want to follow
up on that because you know thin prints
is the area in the bar where there's
no volume either on the offer side or
the bid side in the two-way auction that
actually traded I mean it's going to be
bid and offered there right it's going
to be here at the 88 and a half bid
offered at 88 and three quarters but
nothing traded at 88 and a half even
here at when it was 88 three-quarters
bid at 89 nothing traded there right so
you got zero zero okay and these are
significant levels because it's telling
you that the market is moving uh pretty
quick okay so you know on the order
flows Trader we do have a setting on
there which makes it easy for you to
identify these areas and it's just uh
you go into the settings and you scroll
down
um find the thin print here most of it's
alphabet
alphabetized
um so that puts us here thin prints okay
I'm going to draw it out until tested
and click apply and just give it a
second and I'm going to scroll back to
the cache open to sort of take you back
uh to the cash opening time you know
it's interesting because I got uh
there's a comment yesterday on one of
the videos and so it's well you got to
show this stuff in real time okay well
you know these videos are meant to teach
you what to look for so when you're
trading the market you have an idea of
what to look for I mean I could sit here
and make a video just all day long
recording but you know I'm not going to
do that because it'd be very boring for
a lot of times where there's nothing
happening in the market so really these
videos are instructional to teach you
what to look for so when you are sitting
at home in front of your screen you know
following the order flow or even trading
the order flow you'll know what to look
for okay so where's Cash open here 8 30
okay so you know 8 30 opened up and
again we're more or less going sideways
for the first uh 10 minutes you start to
pop up a little bit come back down into
our sideways activity and then we start
working our way higher now these are
thin prints from the overnight session
and I'm not going to put too much weight
in the thin prints from you know the the
overnight session at you know even going
back earlier to you know sixth in the
morning where there's not a lot of
volume going through right six in the
morning Chicago time is around lunchtime
in in the UK and Europe so that's why
you'll notice you know if you
watch the order flow long enough you
know that you know around that six a.m
time you know the volume is much lighter
you know good time in terms of in case
you're wondering
um what's a good time to be trading
um overnight is you know that that's
sort of the time that Europe opens you
know from
2 A.M to about 4 a.m right you get good
volume you can see in here
um 1600 1800 4700
um so it's decent size volume right you
don't want to
be trying to analyze thin prints or lack
of volume on bars that have very little
volume right just because it sort of
defeats its purpose because by Nature on
a less liquid time right you're going to
get thin Prints but you know if you're
trading healthy volume like look at that
we had this nice move up
um after Europe opened right you've seen
thin print thin print thin print thin
print now granted this one this one this
one it's on very light volume 187
contracts in this bar 201 150
um then 500 but 1600 is decent right
4700 is decent and we we pop up right
but really this one is is the one that
you could have
um if you're if you're awake at uh if
you're in the US and you're awake at
that time this was a nice bar to trade
right we had nice heavy volume
um coming in and it's the bar is
elongated so you know there's a little
bit of volatility you know Traders are
looking for liquidity in the market and
they're just leaving these sort of
pockets of illiquidity okay and you
could have caught a nice move up but
anyway let's go back to the cash open
okay
sort of digress there I apologize
um you know more or less just going
sideways you know
this is Cash open here
um yeah you got the thin print here next
bar goes inside you got thin print here
Mark is just going down but again we're
sort of trading in this range we're not
seeing these thin prints
as we're attempting to trade higher
outside of this area that we're range
bound or trade lower right it's
literally right smack in the middle of
the range that we're trading right then
eventually start going higher okay after
you know nine o'clock you do have a thin
print coming in here you know we sort of
already starting to break out to the
upside okay that's encouraging but again
I know that we're coming up to the
opening price at 85 and you know I've
said this uh many times in the past is
you know on a market that lacks
direction for the day you often will
hang around the opening price and this
was 85 was the opening price that's the
price we opened up on Sunday
um yesterday at 5 PM Chicago time so
ever the market had the whole entire
time to digest everything that happened
uh lit Friday and you know the entire
week and close like at 87 I forgot 87
and three quarters or something like
that so a little bit lower but
nevertheless we get back up there and we
just sort of rotate around it okay for
you know let's say 9 13. up until you
know it looks like we're potentially
starting to break out here right we've
got that stack buying imbalance but then
the next bar doesn't even build off it
doesn't go any higher in fact it just
goes inside and starting to trade down
right and then trading back into our
opening price got the stack selling a
balance and it looks like okay maybe
we're going to break lower we're gonna
finally move away because we had been
trading uh sideways for about this is 9
13 over here is 9 30 so you know 50 you
know it was at 17 minutes
right then it doesn't even break down it
doesn't even trade any lower than the
bar with the stack cell and a balance
there's no reason to be looking to get
short
off the selling and balance and we're
just back up at 85 back and forth again
then we start working our way up here
and as we're working our way up we get
this
thin print here at six and three
quarters two more here at 88 and a half
and 88 and three quarters our high for
this sort of this range that we were
trading you know is 89 and a quarter we
actually trade all the way up to 90 and
a quarter so what you really want to be
watching for is you know are we going to
hold this this area up in here you know
Above This high at 89 and a quarter the
trigger is these one two three zero
prints in the bar the thin prints okay
now you'll notice there's no you have a
lot of buying imbalances in here but no
stack buying imbalance right you got two
here then regular order flow another one
here
more regular order flow to imbalances
regular order flow
um an imbalance regular order flow
another imbalance so it's spread out in
the bar
again if you're just looking for stacked
imbalances you may not
um notice that right you may overlook
this but you know if you're looking at a
bar and it's got a lot of buying
imbalances even if it's spread out
that's still important but if more
importantly if you're looking for the
thin prints in the bar the zero the zero
zero here you know that hey you know
what I've got some momentum obviously
you know you're keying it in together
with the imbalances and next bar starts
trading higher right that's your goal
signal that's your time to get get into
the market right to get long here and
you start trading higher work our way up
grinding a little sideways here once we
work our way up not new Highs but you
know new highs from the cash open
um our high of the day it was up here at
one and a quarter and we're just sort of
slowly grinding our way up and as you're
moving up more importantly
there's no reason to
be getting out of this trade or look to
get short because is there any really
aggressive selling we had this one bar
here with a negative Delta of minus 231
everything else is all positive Deltas
here you got some negative Deltas but
minus 69 minus 46 that's nothing that's
pretty small right it's not minus 690
followed by minus 460. it's minus 69 is
minus 46 so it's relatively tight
telling you that you know what even
those sellers were in control of that
bar and Delta ending at minus 69 it's
still not that strong right the minus 46
also not that strong and got to remember
at one point these deltas
looking at the Min Delta was minus 175
minus 115. and it only closed at minus
69 from 175 so it gave back a lot even
here was minus 115 only finished at
minus 46 and you get a small Delta here
of 11 then it gets building 84 105 327
429 as it's starting to make its run up
to the highs and finally we poke up
there make a new high by one tick you
get a little bit of selling coming in
right so again you know if you're long
from the 91 area
you know trade all the way up to new
Highs at all one and a half you know and
then you see some selling coming in
you know still problem getting out in
here no shame in getting out here around
the 97 area after you see the selling
strong selling come in here and here
um we did pull back all the way down to
you know what was that I think it's only
back down to 91.
before working your way sideways
eventually we came all the way up here
to New Highs at two and a half but our
two and was that two and three quarters
and then um three and a quarter
did you get another uh zero print in
here and another zero print in here but
really the the good trade to take the
best trade to take was
um off this bar with the three
um thin prints in it okay and you see
how it just worked its way up nice and
methodically
so you know that's the value of looking
at thin prints right remember order flow
is not always about concentrating on the
heavy volume a big bid coming in or a
big offer coming in yeah that they're
important they're part of the whole
order flow
um puzzle and all that but you also got
to pay attention to those areas where
there's that lack of trading in the
two-way auction all right everybody so I
hope you got something useful out of
this video and I'll see you guys on the
next video bye-bye
thank you